You want to represent while on the path.
Jock was a store called Jocko store
tee shirts.
If you wear tee shirts, do
you know, check them out.
Discipline equals freedom tee shirts,
lightweight hoodies,
light and heavy, whatever
you need, whatever you like.
And some other cool stuff.
Rash guards as good to have more than
one rash guard for multiple reasons.
I'm going to do a warrior kid rash guard
stand by to get some white tea Jocko
white tea available,
travel amongst
women's stuff,
some tank tops and whatnot.
Pat's bold flex fit.
Then trucker hats patches to if you want
to represent the path that we're all on
this in the mail,
go store.com if you like something good.